[Applaudissements]
ODI qu'est-ce que c'est et ben c'est ce
que je suis en train de faire maintenant
et puis je peux vous dire que ce n'est
pas facile
au début je n'ose pas et puis
comment Marie a réussi à me convaincre
je me lance et dans ce sens je suis un
peu comme le baril de poudre et il est
l'étincelle
et il est venu comme ça une fois avec
une idée un super projet il m'a dit
j'aimerais que tu deviennes la première
parasycliste à réaliser le raid pyrénéen
c'est quoi leur être pyrénéen la
traversée des Pyrénées de l'Atlantique à
la Méditerranée 800 km 18000 mètres de
dénivelé positif en 10 jours et à la
force des bras bien sûr
ce projet m'enthousiasmé vraiment je
trouvais que c'était génial mais en même
temps j'avais des appréhensions j'avais
des craintes je pensais déjà aux côtés
de l'organisation comment faire mes
traitements pour le handicap durant un
tel périple et puis je pensais aussi que
aux inflammations aux blessures que cela
pourrait occasionner parce que à ce
moment là j'étais encore en plein dans
ma carrière sportive de handbike et
j'avais des comptes à rendre à mes
sponsors à ma fédération sportive qui
s'attendait aux résultats auxquels moi
je les avais habitués
mais j'ai vaincu ces appréhensions je
les fais et j'ai réussi et c'est vrai
que c'était extraordinaire j'ai pu être
la première parasite à réaliser ce défi
ouvrir une voix et même faire encore une
étape du gyroditalie après que j'ai pu
gagner et tout ça ça m'a donné
l'énergie et ça m'a montré que
finalement
on y allant et ben
on découvre on a des forces en soi qui
sont
insoupçonnés et finalement on peut se
poser la question c'est quoi
oser
oser est-ce que c'est
de la rébellion est-ce que c'est de
l'audace
est-ce que c'est du courage
au diable disait
il vaut mieux parfois se taire et passer
pour un con que de parler et de ne
laisser aucun risque à se aucun doute à
ce sujet
et ben
ce soir je prends ce risque
je pense que
oser demande une certaine forme de
courage parce que
l'échec est envisageable
à la base je n'ai pas du tout de
facilité à parler en public mais j'ai
appris je me suis formée je me suis
laissée conseiller
d'ailleurs enfant j'étais très timide et
je m'épanouis c'est à travers la
gymnastique la danse l'acrobatie j'en ai
même fait mon métier en devenant
trapéziste et contorsionniste
après 15 ans dans ce magnifique métier
j'ai chuté du trapèze et je me suis je
me suis retrouvée telle que vous me
voyez maintenant par appeler GIC
et
à ce moment là
j'avais tout perdu mon identité le
travail de ma vie et j'ai eu cette image
dans château de sable
je ressentais mon corps comme un château
de sable tous mes accomplissements qui
ont pu être balayé par une grosse vague
par une intempéries
tout au long de notre vie nous prenons
des rôles tantôt nous sommes parents
sportifs artistes hommes d'affaires
et tout ça c'est un peu comme des
châteaux de sable
quand j'étais artiste je disais bien je
suis artiste comme nous avons tous
l'habitude de le faire
je disais je suis mais en fait ce
n'était qu'un rôle que je prenais le
temps
dernier épisode de ma vie
mais qui sommes-nous
lorsque nous perdons
notre couple notre travail
notre vie quand tout cela ressemble à ce
château de sable qui se fait engloutir
par une grosse vague
après l'accident des amis m'avaient dit
il faudrait que tu fasses du sport de
haut niveau mais je n'osais pas
réinvestir dans quelque chose qui était
autant axé sur le corps physique que je
ressentais comme si vulnérable si
délicate il fragile comme ce château de
sable qui aurait pu de nouveau
s'écrouler
jusqu'à ce que je prenne conscience que
finalement ce n'est pas le but
l'objectif qui était important mais tous
les souvenirs les enseignements les
émotions que nous gagnons au cours du
chemin
et puis finalement qu'il existe des
fondements mais les fondements ne sont
pas là où je pensais au début dans les
murs solides de nous accomplissement
les fondements sont dans quelque chose
de bien plus subtil
dans l'autre intérieur dans notre cœur
dans nos pensées
et ces fondements
c'est ce qui m'est resté après
l'accident j'avais tout perdu j'avais
perdu mes relations j'avais perdu ma vie
le travail d'une vie j'avais perdu mon
corps tel que je le connaissais
mais il me restait à l'intérieur de moi
de la volonté de la détermination de la
discipline personnelle
et c'est ça que j'ai pris
ces fondements solides subtils en moi
pour reconstruire pour reconstruire des
nouveaux châteaux de sable
parce que je savais je n'avais plus peur
je me disais que même si ça devait
échouer j'avais cette force en moi pour
rebondir pour recommencer
et c'est ainsi que je me suis lancé dans
une carrière de handbike pendant 10 ans
j'ai fait des nombreuses compétitions
c'est ainsi que
j'ai entamé cette collaboration avec les
PFL pour le développement de
l'exosquelette twice qui était au début
pas du tout ce à quoi il ressemblait
maintenant
et c'était très difficile il fallait
tout mettre en place mais vous savez au
début quand
je me mettais de un départ de course de
handbike toujours j'avais peur j'avais
peur d'un nouvel accident j'avais peur
d'un carambolage j'avais peur de me
renverser dans les virages parce que
dans les courses les athlètes sont très
agressifs et imprévisibles parce que
tout le monde veut gagner
mais j'ai sûrementé ces peurs je les
fais et avec l'exosquelette aussi
au début où il n'était pas encore autant
développé que maintenant j'avais peur de
perdre le contrôle de la machine j'avais
peur de foncer dans un obstacle j'avais
peur de tomber
mais j'ai poursuivi j'ai continué
et
si je n'avais pas été au départ de ses
cours si je n'avais pas surmonté cette
peur jamais je n'aurais pu vivre toutes
ces émotions sportives extraordinaires
jamais je n'aurais pu gagner toutes ces
toutes ces médailles c'est records du
monde c'est médailles au niveau
international
si je n'avais pas persévéré avec ses
entraînements de l'exosquelette qui
était vraiment difficile au début
jamais nous n'aurions pu amener cet
appareil à l'état où il est aujourd'hui
et apporter une indépendance et une
liberté de mouvement à toutes les
personnes qui sont en mobilité réduite
et dans cette même continuité
si je n'avais pas
ouvert cette porte de la peur
pour aller chercher ce qui se cachait
derrière
jamais je n'aurais pu recevoir le plus
beau cadeau de ma vie qui a été se
retour
à ma première passion à mes premiers
amours ce retour à mon métier d'artiste
de cirque
j'ai pu inventer 13 ans après l'accident
une technique qui me permet de bloquer
les parties paralysées de mon corps
et ainsi me mettre en équilibre sur les
mains
j'ai recréé un spectacle en numéro
et vous n'imaginez pas
la première fois que je suis retournée
sur scène
quoi mon corps tremblait
mon cœur battait la chamade
c'était affreux le trac que j'avais
d'ailleurs que j'ai toujours mais
[Applaudissements]
mais je le sais et j'avais peur j'avais
peur de la réaction du public parce que
aller sur scène avec un handicap je ne
savais pas comment ça allait être reçu
je ne savais pas si j'allais réussir
à réaliser la performance telle que je
l'avais entraînée je ne savais pas si
j'allais réussir à transmettre ce
message
d'espoir de force intérieure que je
j'avais envie de transmettre à travers
mes gestes et puis je crois que
[Musique]
les applaudissements du public
ont été pour moi cette lumière qui se
cache
derrière cette porte de la peur que vous
pouvez ouvrir si vous faites un pas si
vous osez faire le pas le premier pas et
le suivant et je vais juste vous montrer
à quoi ça ressemble pour que mes mots et
des images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien ce soir j'ai envie de vous dire
vous aussi vous pouvez créer créer des
œuvres créer des châteaux de sable même
s'ils sont voués à disparaître
ne vous laissez pas arrêter et bloquer
par cette peur parce que vous savez que
les fondements ils sont en vous que en
vous il y a cette force
cette force qui vous permet de vous
relever quoi qu'il arrive si un château
se fait branler et ben vous en aurez
récolté des accomplissements
et
j'ai envie de vous dire
là ce soir moi assise sur mon trône je
préfère être
la reine des connes que d'être un mouton
dans la tête ne dépasse pas du troupeau
alors
sortez du troupeau et rejoignez-moi
[Applaudissements]